[Music]
i would love to start with you um you
helm a lot of the show's pivotal
episodes i would argue you know from
behind the camera
what was it about the project that drew
you to it specifically
you know dan erickson came up with this
this script and he had not been produced
as a writer and it came through our
doors and i i was immediately
taken by the tone and sort of the
influences in it that felt uh
very original but also familiar and i
and something i hadn't seen before in
terms of um
just the world of this show and uh the
concept the very simple concept that he
came up with so i was immediately
in and it's taken a number of years to
get it to this point it's really it's
been like i think maybe five years since
or more i i forget when i first called
you adam because i read it i called adam
up uh
immediately too because he was the first
person i thought of to be mark
january 2017
really
yeah
wow
wow so it's like exactly five years ago
that's crazy isn't that crazy
yeah i remember i was standing in the
snow
outside of the place i was staying in
sundance
right
it's so weird that i remember exactly oh
my god yeah adam i feel is it fair to
say that you were probably involved with
this project before you even knew about
it i i saw that dan had envisioned you
for this character of mark
probably before you were even aware of
it
i mean that's so flattering and and and
nice uh to hear i mean i i from the
moment dan or from the moment ben kind
of gave me the big idea of the show um
while i was standing in the snow uh in
2017. uh i just couldn't stop thinking
about it because
it's just
such a great idea it's one of those
ideas you can't believe no one's
explored it before
and then a couple years later i actually
got to read a script and it's just
exactly the kind of thing that i
like to watch as a as an audience member
and it had everything in it it had this
like fun workplace comedy um just with
this weird sinister vibe underneath it
it has you know satire and and and uh
kind of thriller elements and suspense
and science fiction had all this
terrific stuff yet it's completely
character driven um so as an actor it
was just a dream role and truly felt
like something i've been waiting my
whole career to to be able to to do um
in terms of your approach to the
character
i you're playing somebody who in the
world of the show has been severed so
your your work life and your
and your life life you know the memories
are completely separate do you look at
it as playing two separate people or is
it more you're playing
two halves of the same person
definitely the latter um
it had to be
the same guy and
just have it be a matter of
addition or subtraction from one to the
other what does the one on the inside uh
not have that the one on the outside
does it's a whole life of experience but
what does the one on the inside have
that the outside does not there there
are different things and they manifest
themselves in different ways some
physical and and some emotional um so it
was a a constant sort of dance figuring
that out as we went along and and
luckily i had been there to
to to sort of augment and keep track of
because we were shooting the whole show
it at once so keeping everything um
straight and which which in-ear audi we
were doing and where we were in the
story was always a really fun puzzle to
work out it's a great visual journey
it's a great character story i'm
actually all out of time but again thank
you both so much for talking about the
show i genuinely cannot wait for
everyone to see this and and kind of go
through all the twists and turns like i
did and i and i hope we get to see more
thank you so much